In lecture, Dave introduce the Rabin-Miller test for primality.
For this assignment, I want you to implement this test.
The Rabin-Miller function your going to write will take in a number
that may be composite or prime and target, which defines the desired probability level.
The default value 128 corresponds to a probability of 1/2^128.
Two useful routines are the module exponentiation function
that we've been using throughout this unit and randrange,
which is a function of the Python library, that returns a random integer
a random integer between start and end.
I haven't provided any tests, but you should be able to find some prime and composite numbers
to test with on your own.
There is some randomness, so there is a small chance the test will return True for a composite number,
but if your target is set high enough--and 128 should be pretty high.
It's very unlikely that this will happen.